good morning my name is john hanchar
i am with cornell university and a
member of the cornell university hemp
group
that is stunning hemp production in new
york state
lindsey paschall and mary ulrich also
with cornell university and i've been
doing research and extension work
on the economic aspects of growing hemp
in new york
lindsay mary and i will be presenting
update type information
from an economics perspective based upon
our cost of production work i will
describe the economic environment
the market signals which growers
considered earlier in the year regarding
planting decisions
lindsay will then provide update
information for processing retail and
consumer activities
mary will discuss what do growers need
to be thinking of
to obtain viable hemp enterprises
cost of production and expected prices
are key determinants of growers planting
decisions
should i produce or not if production
makes sense then how much
should i plan to supply at expected
prices
acreage and production input decisions
are involved
item one figure one contains information
produced by cornell university and
others
for cornell university resources please
see
hemp dot cals.cornell.edu
cornell analysis for a plastic culture
system
suggests variable costs and total costs
equal twelve
thousand six hundred and thirteen
thousand one hundred dollars per acre
respectively the cornell work excludes a
charge for the value of management
inputs required
and reflects pre-planting inputs tasks
to the point where dry
material is in totes ready for immediate
delivery
or ready for storage and future delivery
item two the other studies
use similar cost to production methods
but the items included in time periods
considered differed
for example the university of
connecticut values
include a charge for management inputs
required
various marketing expenses and others
variable costs for the five study ranged
from eight thousand eight hundred
dollars
to thirteen thousand four hundred
dollars per acre
the five study average was twelve
thousand two hundred dollars per acre
for the variable cost measure
total costs ranged from nine thousand
two hundred dollars
to nineteen thousand three hundred
dollars
per acre the five study average
was fourteen thousand dollars per acre
item three calculated break even prices
the expected prices received that would
cover variable
and total cost using the five study
averages
equaled 1.31 and 1.51
dollars per percent cbd per pound of dry
matter
respectively given percent cbd
equals six dry matter per plant equal
one pound
and harvested plants per acre equal 1550
plants expected prices for the 2020
growing and harvest year
late 2019 of about a dollar
and early 2020 about
65 cents relative to cost suggests a
relatively
unfavorable economic environment for
hemp cbd
item four in summary
there are three aspects that this
information supports
an unvei unfavorable economic
environment unfavorable market signals
was being considered by growers as they
made
planting decisions early in the year
especially when compared to expectations
for alternative horticulture crops
risks and uncertainties still concern
growers a comment by mary ulrich cce
eastern new york horticulture program
during a recent cornell university hemp
check-in call
summarizes the environment quite well
activity that is hemp production is a
fraction
of what it was last year in the area
if you have questions or comments you
can contact me john hanchar
at jjh6 cornell.edu
thank you